[موسيقى]
مع التأخر في منزلي أ
تصدي نعم للفقر
تكاليف السكن ممكن
هو كل الحق في الأخلاق والأخلاق دي البحر
مستوى
بسبب عمل الأشياء لديها ما يلزم ل
نظرية الكيس الطويل
زين
اللى
الساحة رقاقة كيف يمكن أن يكون هناك ثاني نفسك
دبابيس تقشير صاروخ عبر الحارة
ركض بشرتي القانونية
يجب أن يكون أقصر ويمكن أن يكون على ملف
استمر اذهب
نحن قليلاً في الزواج الأحادي tp man in
ممكن الدعاء ناقص تفكير السيارة
إلى البرج الأسود في شيكاغو
ونعيش الميزانية ونجعلها تعمل
لتظهر على الحائط هنا
هنا قال آخر الشجاع لماذا
سجل كيف تريد ولايات يا فان
يمكن كيف ليس لدي أجهزة الإفطار
لا تذهب الآن الربيع الأسنان معقولة
نظرة جافة ومرحاض في ذلك واحد من قبل
أكاديمية ضخمة بالطبع
آلة من ناسا نريد هذه القطعة
له وهكذا ضع عشك على طول الطريق
قال لي ماذا عن الاخرين
لا يزال